after everything we've lived through
every loss and every sacrifice
japan decided to start quietly
it's been a long hard road but finally
tokyo is ready to light the way out of a
pandemic
right up until the last seconds they
protested outside
[Music]
others came to the roads around the
stadium just to feel their home olympics
almost everyone else watched at home
this is as close as they'll get
the paired back parade was a gathering
from all corners of the world
the organizers think they are all
covered free
you are true olympic athletes
watching all this here in tokyo is now
actually no different to watching it
anywhere else in the world it's only on
tv you can
join in on your smartphone and tap and
clap away and cheer but
it's not the same as it but it is still
the olympic games
still the pinnacle for so many of our
athletes when you go through tough times
with people
you realize how much hard graft they've
put in and to now be here
be in tokyo training on the pitch it's
all coming true
i think that's really special in a
moment that we all need to embrace
because
we've had a lot of hard work to get here
and actually now it's just a fun bit
team gb's star sprinter dina asha smith
was a games maker volunteer back in
london 2012.
her moment comes into games when podium
protests will still
cause controversy but the rules on
taking the knee
have been relaxed if somebody does
decide to take a knee and it was still
banned i
couldn't understand how the ioc was
actually going to enforce that
in terms of would you take away
somebody's medal would you penalize
somebody for being against racism
like how on earth was that ever going to
go down
japanese tennis star naomi osaka was
given the crowning moment
but nobody knows how these games will
play out
it is a global experiment that's now
live
tom parmenter sky news tokyo